this was the moment of arrest
on a driveway in North Dighton
Massachusetts 21 year old Jack Tashira
is walked backwards towards armed FBI
agents into the back of an armored
vehicle and custody
he is the young Airman accused of using
an internet chat room to chat National
Secrets hundreds of them over months
until his capture
today the justice department arrested
Jack Douglas deshara in connection with
an investigation into alleged
unauthorized removal retention and
transmission of classified National
Defense information
the Ukraine conflict featured in the
published material which the leaker said
he'd brought home from work until
military base Russia featured in
documents suited North Korea Israel and
a host of countries friend and full
The Washington Post interviewed a member
of the chat room who new to Shira by his
chat room name OG he was a young
charismatic Man Who Loved nature God Who
Loved shooting guns and and racing cars
the documents were posted on Discord an
instant messaging platform popular with
gamers they're believed to have been
posted on a server named Thug Shaker
Central as early as mid-January by the
leaker who called himself OG he shared
typed out versions and then screenshots
to a group of around 20 friends
dozens of documents relating to the
Ukraine war were then posted on a
different server making them widely
available
the Pentagon says it's still examining
the scope scale and impact of the leak
they can add embarrassment it is
important to understand
that we do have stringent guidelines in
place for safeguarding classified and
sensitive information this was a
deliberate criminal act at the same news
conference the Pentagon spokesman says
it takes seriously the safety of its
personnel and its allies the very fact
that needed restating reflects renewed
questions about U.S intelligence its
integrity and security
it is the story of the young man dog
duji who inflicted the security on goal
he was sharing Secrets long before his
government found out the ramifications
will last long after